e eu assisto me terror de madrugada e de
madrugada é o seguinte quando você
assistir um filme de terror que
geralmente ele começa a 11 horas e ele
acaba depois da meia-noite rebete rebete
rebete rebete gente é um mar droga
autoconfiante embora pai filme de terror
madrugadinha é baseado em fatos reais eu
dou uns 16 17 anos para frente eu já
morava sozinho e o boi Você mora sozinha
que você mora sozinho né ali sozinho
agora O ruim é que você mora
sozinho né sozinho só normal é só com
força mesmo né tipo assim você tá
sozinha ali na sala e sua mãe tá no
banheiro é você tá ali na sala e a loira
do banheiro tá no banheiro ver o filme
de terror ele Começa umas horas da noite
mas termina depois da meia-noite eu
tenho a superação que é o seguinte para
mim depois da meia-noite o Satanás ele
começa a andar por dentro da sua casa e
o fio é baseado em fatos reais eu traga
a realidade do filme para minha vida
senão filme tiver uma muriçoca muriçocas
em pneu de meu Deus Essa Melissa tu vai
me matar cara eu nunca te fiz nada